today on the matt well show trans
activists want to kill me for making
what is a woman they've told me this
themselves what does that say about
gender ideology also texas legislators
move to ban child drag shows that's a
law that shouldn't be needed but it is
and aoc officially endorses the term
latinx or latinx in our daily
cancellation a college professor cancels
pirates including fictional pirates
they're all canceled apparently they
weren't woke enough who knew all of that
and more today on the matt wall show
[Music]
did you know that if you're currently on
a phone plan with one of the major
carriers you're helping these
left-leaning companies donate to
pro-choice causes of candidates common
question i get from my listeners is what
can i do to help turn the tides in the
culture war well here's a great first
step defund the abortionist don't let
them take your money and use it to
further policies that you don't believe
in switch to charity mobile today and
they will send five percent of your
monthly plan price to any pro-life
charity of your choice charity mobile
offers the latest 5g phones with no
device or service contracts plus great
nationwide coverage if this sounds like
a hassle i assure you it is not
charitable charity mobile makes
switching from your current carrier
painless their live customer service is
exceptional they'll guide you through
the process you can keep your number and
and even keep your phone in most cases
or if you want you can take advantage of
my special offer and get a free cell
phone with free activation all you have
to do is call 1-877-474-3662
or chat with them online at
charitymobile.com and mention offer code
walsh to redeem the free cell phone
offer that's charitymobile.com mention
offer code walsh join the fight for life
today by switching to charity mobile
well my new film what is a woman is now
the most successful piece of content the
daily wire has ever produced record
numbers of people have watched it the
film has been trending online for days
it's easily one of the most talked about
and debated films of the year uh it's
been an enormous smash success and
already made i think an immediate and
seismic impact on the culture none of
this would have been possible without
you guys in the audience supporting the
film and supporting our mission more
broadly by subscribing to the daily wire
you know we're trying to build something
so that we can continue making films
like what is a woman and other sorts of
films and pieces of content that will
impact the culture in different but
still important ways so if you haven't
subscribed yet i'd ask you to consider
going to what is a woman.com getting
signed up uh we may not have the whole
you know extensive content library of
like netflix not yet anyway but we're on
a mission and uh we're making art that
matters we're kind of the um the way i
look at it is kind of the scrappy
underdogs the unwelcome
intruders in the subscription streaming
world right now but there's a lot of fun
to be had
in that role that's the good news and it
enables us to make things that literally
nobody else anywhere else could or would
ever make
like what is woman
now one of the reasons why
nobody would make what is a woman is
because the subject matter is of course
radioactive i mean gender ideology is
the ultimate third rail it's
supercharged considered untouchable by
most people
there are increasing numbers of people i
think who will kind of dance around the
edges of the issue talk about sports
teams and bathrooms and that sort of
thing but very few people will go after
the heart of this thing
it's one thing to suggest that males
don't belong in women's bathrooms
it's another thing to call into question
the actual underlying premise of gender
ideology and transgenderism
the thing is as it turns out even if
you're trying to stay around the edges
it doesn't really work because
you can't make an argument against males
and women's bathrooms without
questioning the underlying premise if
you're trying to keep the underlying
premise intact and say nothing about
that
then you've already surrendered the
entire issue
so that's what we try to do in this film
is go after the underlying premise
premise and because we succeeded so
dramatically in exposing the hollowness
at the core of this ideology
and because we knew we had succeeded we
also knew that
there would be
blowback you know to releasing this
though of course there was never any
thought given to not releasing it this
is a bomb you know in effect
metaphorically and it's a bomb that we
knew we had to detonate come what may
and as for what is coming my way now
there are um the expected things that
we've talked about you know coordinated
campaigns to de-platform me lies and
smears and defamation being spread about
me even to the point of leftists
photoshopping tweets to try to embarrass
and libel me every day i see a new tweet
that i that i never tweeted that's
making the rounds online
um
this was the extent of the backlash
until the last day or two
when the death threats started rolling
in uh we have our security team tracking
those and the police have been notified
might have a little bit more specific
on those uh threats soon but for now
i'll just leave it at that
um also i should note that i'm an avid
fan of the second amendment and uh more
than willing to make full use of my
constitutional rights should any of
these keyboard warriors decide to try to
you know try their luck in the real
world but the death threats are
sometimes not as revealing as the death
wishes and there are
a great many of those on twitter right
now directed at me
um most people are most people anyway
are hesitant to make explicit physical
threats
and um the people who have not been
hesitant to make those physical threats
are going to learn why they ought to
have been
but a lot of people are are you know
much more confident and feel a lot
better about especially trans activists
who are some of the most vicious and
cowardly people on the planet
they're not as shy about telling you
what they hope happens to you because
they feel like that gives them a little
bit of cover
so just a few examples i mentioned the
death threats that we've been getting
on twitter yesterday i mentioned it and
um and here's how leftists and trans
activists responded i'm gonna read a few
here just a few examples
one says seeing fascist bigots scared
for their life is so satisfying another
hopefully the cops are as effective at
protecting you and your family as they
were at protecting the children and
teachers in uvalde another says you
deserve all of it another says you
deserve worse another says haha good i
look forward to hearing how the cops
stood around and watched another says
hopefully some of those threats have
some weight behind them another says
rotten hell i hope somebody carries them
out another one says lmfao hope someone
pulls through when you're actively
discrediting and threatening the lives
of thousands of trans people all over
you deserve to get your
rocked
another one says
fingers crossed they're credible and you
get the idea hundreds more where that
came from i mean hundreds
they're also posting this stuff in their
own circles online for example one
account posted a fake obituary for me
which said breaking american political
commentator and podcaster matt walsh has
passed away in his tennessee home
further details have yet to be
determined
and i responded to that post with a link
to whatiswoman.com and they immediately
deleted it another account posted rt if
you think matt walsh should never enjoy
another moment of peace as long as he
lives that tweet had 3000 likes and i
responded to that one with a link to the
website as well and he also deleted it
there are again hundreds if not
thousands of tweets like this a great
many of them are
apparently without a hint of sarcasm or
irony accusing me of committing genocide
that's their words committing genocide
against trans people
and of course i deserve to die they say
i've committed genocide
with a documentary
my documentary is apparently it's like
that movie the ring you know remember
that it was the early 2000s where if you
watched it a monster would come out of
the screen and kill you in some
unspecified but really disturbing way
that's what they seem to think anyway
but they could find out for sure if they
went to what is woman.com and became a
subscriber today
now
uh i want to make uh just a few points
about this and the first is that there
are some who will sort of dismiss
this by saying that well this is how
people are on the internet happens on
both sides they'll say and that's that's
not totally true i mean even if it was
it wouldn't make it okay obviously but
that's not totally true yes i mean
anyone on any side of any issue may
receive a death threat or two if they
get a lot of negative attention for
something they said
and yes there are anonymous trolls
posting heinous stuff on both sides
but
anyone who's ever poked the gender
ideology beehive
knows that trans activists are uniquely
vicious and feel especially entitled to
say and do whatever they want
as someone who has a lot of experience
poking various beehives including
literal beehives as we talked about
yesterday um i can say for sure that
that no group is quite like the trans
activist in this regard
i mean even take like blm we know what
blm is willing to do
well i've said a lot of things and done
a lot of things to upset blm and i've
gotten the blow back for it but it's
never quite like this
so why is it like this with the
left-wing trans activist well it's
partly because they're amoral
narcissists
partly because they've been emboldened
by social media platforms and by every
other institution
to act out in whatever that way they
they want without consequence
and it's partly because
as previously mentioned
they've told themselves this delusional
story and been told this delusional
story that anyone who criticizes their
worldview is a clear and present danger
to their very physical existence
one trans activist summarized this
delusion quite well in response to my
tweet about the death threats i received
and uh it said here's the thing
we trans people are not prepared to be
removed from society the fact that you
were prepared for death threats means
that this is an operation a planned move
to kill us
you are inciting violence we are backed
into a corner with a knife to our throat
you see with my documentary i have
backed them into a corner with a knife
to their throat
and this gives them the moral right to
kill my whole family they really believe
that
at least they want to believe it and
they've worked very hard to fool
themselves into taking this kind of
delusional hysterical nonsense seriously
this is the consequence by the way the
the
intended consequence of the words are
violence
nonsense
because it empowers people like this it
gives them the excuse to be even more
vile and vicious than they were already
inclined to be
it's also the consequence of our
societal obsession with affirmation
you know these activists have come to
believe
that they have a god-given human right
to be affirmed
that is to have everyone in the world
agree with them
and reinforce their self-perception
and they are so convinced of this notion
that when they encounter a non-affirming
opinion or thought or film
they take it as a threat to their lives
they don't know how to not be affirmed
right like most of us
i i encounter stuff all the time that
doesn't exactly affirm me and my beliefs
so i just that's part of life
i don't break down into tears over it
i don't take it as um it's gonna kill me
like there are no words you can say to
me that the words themselves will kill
me
but over here this is the attitude
they don't know how to operate in a
world that is anything less than 100
affirming all the time everywhere with
no exceptions hollywood makes hundreds
of movies and shows every year that
suck up to them one film is released on
a platform they aren't even subscribed
to which takes the opposite approach and
they feel it gives them moral license to
murder the person responsible for it
when i say the left wants you dead i
mean i say it from experience and it is
actually true
and that brings me to my final point and
i want to be very clear
about this to the people who are posting
these things and making these threats
first of all you don't scare me
your ideology is a threat to society to
children to women
to all people
to reality itself
i'm never going to stop pointing that
out or fighting against you and against
everything you believe
this reaction only cements me even more
in my convictions it radicalizes me even
more than i already was and i didn't
think that i could be any more radical
about it
and it makes me even more convinced than
ever that this film is necessary and
important
and i'm so happy we made it
couldn't be happier and i'll tell you
this
the more you keep this up
the more offensive my next film is going
to be
you're doing this to yourselves
actions have consequences
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
well with price of gas these days it may
seem like there's no upside at the pump
but there is the upside is upside it's
the new app that you have to get my
listeners are earning cash back for
every gallon of gas every time they fill
up don't pay full price of the pump
anymore get cash back using upside all
you got to do is download the app for
free
use promo code walsh for 25 cents per
gallon or more on your first tank and
it's not just for gas you know you can
earn cash back at grocery stores
restaurants
you can earn it with takeout also you
can cash out any time to your bank
account or an e-gift card for select
retailers and brands very simple very
easy you get money back there's no
no downside all upside just download the
free upside app and use promo code walsh
to get 25 cents per gallon or more cash
back on your first tank just use my
promo code walsh right now again that's
the upside app go get it use code walsh
all right let's talk about some
good news someone did how about that for
a change so here's some good news this
is from daley wire it says a texas state
legislator announced on monday that
he'll be introducing legislation to ban
children from being subjected to drag
shows after images from a bar inside
texas went viral over the weekend and
sparked national outrage we talked about
this yesterday obviously to lead the
show the um the drag show for children
at a bar in texas state representative
brian slayton says the events of this
past weekend were horrifying and show a
disturbing trend in which perverted
adults are obsessed with sexualizing
young children as a father or of uh of
two young children i would never take my
children to a drag show and i know
speaker
dade phelan and the rest of my
republican colleagues wouldn't either
slade's remarks come after a gay bar in
dallas generated national outrage with
the drag show we talked about
um slayton continued by noting that it
was not enough for texas republicans to
protect their own children and it was
their responsibility to put an end to
the sexualization that's happening
across texas quote i promised my voters
that i would stand up for their values
and fight to protect texas kid kids i
was re-elected on that promise and i
tend to keep it by authoring legislation
to defend kids from being subjected to
drag shows and other inappropriate
events now
i think this is great for a couple of
reasons and we'll talk about that but i
will also note that
as mentioned yesterday there already is
legislation on the books in texas
that makes this illegal
it's actually there's there's lots of
legislation that that that makes this
illegal everywhere
because this is sexual exploitation of
children
and at least according to the letter of
the law even if the law isn't enforced
sexual exploitation of children is
illegal everywhere
still goes on because the law is not
enforced but it is illegal
and then in texas in particular
they passed a law last year
that specifically states that quote
unquote sexually oriented businesses
and a gay bar with a big sign neon sign
that says it's not going to lick itself
certainly qualifies as a sexually
oriented business
sexually oriented businesses in texas
according to a law passed last year
cannot accept patrons under patrons
under the age of 21 not even 18 year
olds
um and so that's enough right there to
enforce the law you could revoke their
license arrest people
but they're not going to do that and so
you know maybe you you so you come up
with legislation that's much more
explicit and targeted and says no no
okay just so you know
you're not allowed to bring children to
a drag show
we shouldn't need to be that uh
specific about it because it should be
obvious but if that's what's necessary
then it's good thing that this law is
going to be written
and there's another there's another
reason to why um
i think it's good to to make laws like
this and i think republicans all across
the country in every state
should follow suit
and make specific laws
that say you can't bring your kid to a
drag show and the reason you want to do
that even though again
it's it's already illegal according to
the letter of law of the law in any
state
um
but you passed the law anyway
because number one it should hopefully
provide some extra protection for for
these children
you know the the law enforcers can't
can't find a way around it if you're if
you're that explicit about because now
they can always say well is this really
a sexually oriented business you weren't
you weren't specific okay now we're
going to be specific this you have to
enforce this law
but the other advantage to passing a law
like this is that it's a good strategic
move
because it puts democrats in the
position
of
openly defending
child drag shows
which is what they're going to do
in fact it's what they've they've
already started doing this
there are uh you know accounts on social
media from
relatively prominent people on the left
already
you know
offering explicit defenses of children
at drag shows or at least pretending to
be kind of well you know i i don't
understand the criticism maybe someone
can explain the criticism to me it
doesn't it does it's not apparent to me
why this is a problem
trying to strike a you know
quote-unquote moderate position
when there is no moderate position on
child drag shows there's just like the
right position and the wrong position
and if you're not holding the right
position then it's the wrong position
so already you're starting to see but if
you if you now have republican
legislators who are
passing laws like this
that's going to be a situation for the
left and for the democrats where either
they can agree and they can say okay you
know what this this actually is too far
and uh and i agree we need to make that
illegal but they're not going to do that
they're not going to do it because they
don't agree with republicans
they especially don't want to agree with
republicans on anything that that
approaches lgbt issues they can't do
that
and they're not gonna agree with
republicans because they they all
actually do favor
uh child drag shows
they see child drag shows as
very useful tools
um
for sexualizing and indoctrinating kids
so you start passing laws like this and
you are going to see
it's going to start with leftists in
general activists and then eventually
it's going to make its way up to
mainstream democrats
out offering full-throated defenses of
child drag shows
and that's good we want them we already
know they favor it we want them to say
it
okay you want to back them
into a corner
rhetorically where they're going to come
out and say it
so that everyone else can see that this
is what these people want
it'll be just like uh the so-called you
know quote-unquote don't say gay bill
which never actually existed the
anti-groomer bills what it was it would
be just like the anti-groomer bill in
florida all over again
which was a that was massive backlash uh
that was a massive backfire rather for
for the democrats
you know when they were lying at the
bill about about the bill at first they
were getting a little bit of traction
but then once
conservatives kind of got everything
together and started and and got the
messaging together
and people in the public started to
understand what the bill actually
accomplished
then they looked at democrats and said
what you people actually think that we
should talk to
five-year-olds about
about gender fluidity really
massive massive backfire for them and
that that even affected you know disney
and other corporations
so i think we're gonna see something
very similar happen here
um
all right
this is from the daily wire it says on
friday washington post reporter dave
david weigel retweeted a mildly sexist
joke the joke was every girl is bi
you just have to figure out if it's
polar or sexual
that's
kind of funny
uh although although to be honest i i
think it's a little bit of a false
choice because you could be both right i
mean but plenty of maybe there's plenty
of women who are both um
on monday he was suspended without pay
the joke which weigle retweeted from
youtuber cam harlis
was noticed by fellow washington post
reporter felicia sonmez
and she tweeted on her twitter account
fantastic to work at a news outlet where
retweets like this are allowed
according to slack messages obtained by
cnn some mez continued her crusade by
tagging weigel in an internal slack
channel and writing i'm sorry but what
is this she added that the retweet sent
a confusing message about what the post
values are
later on friday weigle wrote i just
removed a tweet of an offensive joke i
apologize and didn't mean to cause any
harm
and then the washington post and then of
course here's the inevitable thing
everything about this is inevitable i
mean we start with the
with the
i wouldn't even call it mildly sexist
like it's just a joke that's all it is
okay um
so we start with the joke and then the
the woman gets offended by it
apology comes all you know every every
step along the way totally inevitable
and then we get to this the washington
post suspended weigel for one month
without pay in the wake of the incident
so i he deleted the tweet he apologized
for it doesn't matter he's still gonna
get suspended and even that's probably
enough i mean they're pushing for him to
get fired they don't want him ever to
come back
because he dared to retweet a joke by
the way sonmez has said that um
has now said that she she has long this
were her words
she said she's long considered dave a
friend
so this is a longtime friend of hers
and she threw him onto the bus
immediately and publicly
because of a joke that he didn't even
tweet the joke he just retweeted it
and then other media people like someone
named goldie taylor uh
has been agreeing i don't know if she
works at washington post because she has
me blocked but
she also said that uh he's a friend but
then she also blasted him publicly over
it
so a couple a couple of takeaways here i
think
the first the first one is that
i have to say once again
as always
there's there's no point in apologizing
in situations like this
it's it's not gonna help you
okay
you're not actually sorry
now there's no point even saying this to
dave dave weigl because he's a leftist
works for the washington post so there's
no hope there anyway
but i will just say that there's no
point apologizing um it's not going to
have any effect
the people who are demanding the apology
uh it they're only demanding it as a
symbolic gesture of submission to them
that's all it is and when you say sorry
for any harm it caused it caused zero
harm
okay find me the woman
who was actually harmed
because david weigel retweeted a
retweeted a joke
on twitter like find me find me that
person
find me i want to find the woman who is
actually
traumatized can't even leave her house
crumpled into a ball
you know sobbing uncontrollably then you
go up to her and you say well what's
wrong what happened
david weigel retweeted a joke like find
me that it doesn't exist nobody's harmed
by it nobody cares
um
and so all you're doing is is choosing
to participate in this charade you're
just playing your role it's like it's
like that all it's just it's a pageant
it's like this like professional
wrestling at this point
and uh i think what you should say is no
i'm not gonna
no
it was a joke you all should apologize
to me for not being able to take a joke
like what what's wrong with you people
i mean it's it's you know
women are always we're always hearing
from feminists that uh that you know
women are just as funny as men
you know i can remember um
way back in in the dark old days when
christopher hitchens wrote that article
i think it was for vanity fair i believe
where he made the argument that uh women
aren't as funny as men and it was a huge
outrage it's like terrible thing you
can't say that well okay so if
everyone's equally as funny then you
gotta be able to take a joke okay you
gotta especially joke like that
it's pretty clever
it's not the funniest joke of all time
but it's pretty clever and you gotta be
able to take jokes like that
if you can't take a joke that you can't
claim to have a sense of humor until you
can't be funny
that should be the response but it
wasn't so we got the apology um and then
the other takeaway here is just
it's just there's no no honor you know
or loyalty among these people whatsoever
just think about that we're used to this
kind of canceling campaign that happens
when
somebody says something and and nobody
really cares but everyone pretends to
care then you've got a bunch of
strangers who are trying to cancel this
person and so we're used to seeing that
but in this case
you work with this guy and he's and he's
been a friend of yours for years
and you don't like something that he
tweeted so the first thing you do is go
publicly and call for him to be
penalized at his work
if someone's a friend like you never
criticize friends publicly
that's not to say you never criticize
friends
but you pull them aside you talk to them
privately
the moment you bring this into the
public especially if that's the first
thing you do
that's not how friendship works
so there's no honor there's no there's
no loyalty at all
but also weigle himself is not a victim
because he apologized and these are the
circles that he runs in i mean if you if
this is if these are the people that you
choose to be friends with then this is
what's going to happen to you
as soon as the as soon as you slip up a
little bit if you step out of line a
little bit according to what according
to the line as they see it like they
have a line for you that you're supposed
to walk in order to maintain this
so-called friendship and the moment that
you waver a little bit off the line
uh then you're dead to them they will
just try to destroy your life that's it
these are the people you choose to
associate with and uh you really you
have it coming not not to victim blame
but i guess i am victor blamey here all
right
so alexander k0 cortez i got a couple
couple good clips from her she um
you understand good in a certain way you
know good as in as in
at least funny so she says that here she
is talking about um democracy and we
once again get a rather depressing
morbid view of democracy which is
especially interesting given the context
but first let's listen to it
this is a lot more than just voting
harder
and it also cuts to the basic structure
of our democracy
if you can call it that
because when you have a
presidency that's not determined by a
popular vote
when you have a senate
where
millions tens of millions of people
more can vote for one candidate one
party
rather one party
and still be in the minority
where even in the house of
representatives that's supposed to
represent
our population
um
that
gets gerrymandered to all hell once and
every once every 10 years in order to
ensure
an outsized minority
rule
and voice in both the house the senate
and the presidency it is becoming
increasingly difficult
for people to defend the stance that we
live in a democracy
in a true one
and
what the real truth of the matter is is
when you look at the fact that's enough
shut up um
so you heard that it's just it's just
interesting given the context that she's
speaking well democracy is dead there's
not a real democracy we don't live in a
democracy
and yet she was
elected
and her party controls
congress and the white house so her
party controls
the entire government
and she's saying that this is all a sham
there's no democracy
i mean what first of all what does that
say about
about how you got into power so is that
is that i mean we shouldn't listen to
you
you're you're a part of this sham system
are you
in fact you've managed to rise to the
top of this system that's a total sham
what does that say about you
and it's just it's really interesting
the way that they the way that they cut
themselves off at the kneecaps because
wouldn't they want to claim that you
know the fact that they're in power they
have the white house they have congress
that wouldn't they want to claim
that this is a reflection of the will of
the people and it gives them a mandate
you know to do what they want to do and
to legislate and they do want to claim
that but at the same time they say oh
the whole system doesn't mean anything
it's all a sham
it's hard to claim both of those things
now she also in a different video she's
promoting and this is
i could be wrong but i think it's one of
the first times she's actually openly
come out and uh addressed this issue of
le tinx you know gender inclusive
language and this uh especially the
gender inclusive the gender inclusivity
that's trying that's that's being
imposed on the spanish language mostly
by white liberal colonialists
and
how does she feel about it well let's
find out
also in the spirit of pride i wanted to
have a note on gender inclusivity in
spanish language
people sometimes like to make a lot of
drama over the term latinx
but even before latinx people were
trying to do this like
it's an ad to have the a and the o
together
gender is fluid language is fluid and i
think people right now are using the e
term as gender neutral in order to be as
inclusive as possible
i just
oh that's so great i actually hadn't
watched the video yet i just knew what
you said i i i
the the audio is so much better because
she tries to give
this kind of spanish accent
to
latinx which is not a word at all and
it's not even a word that can be said
really in the spanish language it just
doesn't it doesn't it doesn't make any
sense in the spanish language it's it's
it's total nonsense
uh especially in a language
that i mean i don't know why i have to i
don't know why am i in a position of
having to teach aoc about spanish
language but apparently i am and so i
have to explain to her that it's a
gendered language like everything is
gendered in in spanish language so
first of all it doesn't even make any
sense to to try to do this if you're not
going to turn every other word
gender neutral also and then at that
point you've just
destroyed the language you've created
it's this is not language changing or
evolving this is just a whole new
language that you've created to supplant
the other one
because the other one was
you you disliked for political and
ideological reasons
but also as i have to keep reminding
people whenever we hear this claim that
latinx or anything whatever else the
pronoun stuff like all of this is just
language is fluid and
um
and it evolves over time
well that's actually true
okay now language in a sense is fluid
and does evolve over time unlike
gender
which which is binary and does not
change it's not fluid does not evolve
over time
um
but that's not what's happening
here okay because a an evolution a
change over time
fluidity of language all that that would
just be
you know you
if if if latinx was being introduced
that way then it would just kind of come
up on its own and it would it would
start
among spanish-speaking people
and they would start using this word and
then it would just kind of make its way
in and that's and that's the way that
language actually does evolve
okay but in this case it's from the
outside
people many of whom don't even speak
spanish
came up with this term that they prefer
for political reasons and are trying to
impose it from the top down onto the
spanish language that is not
that is not language being fluid that is
not language evolving that is
manipulation
that's appropriation that's colonization
of the spanish
language by white lgbt liberals
here's here's a kind of a good rule of
thumb
if there's a change of language
and you can pinpoint the exact moment
where it started like you know who came
up with it
then that's a pretty good indication
that this is not a natural evolution
that just kind of happens on its own
over time
this is someone thought of this and they
would prefer if language worked this way
instead and then in this case worked
through institutions to impose that on
the spanish language
again a totally different
sort of thing all right what else we got
here
uh this one daily wire says new york
democratic governor kathy hokule signed
a 10 bill package of gun laws on monday
that included raising the age to legally
purchase a semi-automatic rifle from 18
to 21 following several recent mass
shootings nationwide
hokule signed the package to immediately
strengthen the state's gun laws and
close critical loopholes quote unquote
as lawmakers seek to decrease shootings
and there are other things happen to
bill too the main thing i just want to
point out here
as we're raising the age from 18 to 21
and we in this in this article we don't
get a much of an explanation because i
don't think there really is one like
very specifically
as to why we're raising it to 21. i mean
what what what what happens at 21 that
isn't happening at 18 that makes it so
that you can um
own these kinds of weapons
when at 18 you can't
but i'd really like to hear from someone
on the left a very specific explanation
of that
you want to raise the age whatever the
weapon is whatever whatever type of gun
we're talking about and whatever age you
want to raise it to
the fact that you want to raise the age
for any kind of gun ownership is very
interesting and i'd love to hear you
very specifically explain why
because i'm guessing that your answer is
going to have a lot to do with
the development of the brain
with the decision-making abilities of of
younger people like that's
probably what this is about right that's
that's that's what you would say
something along those lines
well if that's the case then that raises
a lot of interesting questions about how
you can justify allowing five-year-olds
to choose their gender
okay if an 18 year old
is does not have the capacity to own
certain kinds of firearms
because we can't trust them with it
according to you
and their brain's not developed enough
and they don't have the right kind of
discernment they're not mature enough
they're not you know they don't have
enough critical thinking
long-term planning all those kinds of
things
uh they're too impulsive or whatever
else you would say about them
well then are they able to make
lifelong
bottle you know
body altering decisions for themselves
so 18 you can't own the firearm you're
too young
oh but at five you can certainly make a
decision to change at 12 you can make a
decision to sterilize yourself forever
at 12
but by the time you're 18 you're still
not old enough to be responsible with a
gun
all right one other thing i want to play
for you this is an hr representative
recorded this tick-tock video as i guess
a warning apparently to right-wingers
who post about their views publicly
and she just kind of is warning us and
uh
let's just watch it watch
i'm a recruiter it's a small small small
industry smaller than you'd think same
with hr
so
if you're looking for a job
or maybe trying to keep a job
maybe
just maybe
about what you're putting on social
media
again freedom fighters
i know you're not really big with stats
and
you know facts aren't your thing
you know but what i can tell you what is
the fact is that recruiters talk
and recruiters
like the majority of canada don't agree
with you do you know what that means do
you have any guesses i think that's what
that means what that means is that if
you need a job
you might not get one
if you want to keep a job you might not
get to do that
and
you know what else hr is good at
documentation
you know what that means you want to be
in a
we document it we gave you a couple
tries then what do we do we terminate
you
with cause if we're so lucky
if not we give you the minimum allowed
by law
either way
best of luck to you
recruiters are watching hr is watching
everywhere and we hate you
we hate you so much
and you think we can't do anything but
we can
we have the power
always remember that doesn't matter if
there's a [ __ ] man at the top of your
hr department
it's run by women and it's run by angry
women just like
me you can't watch any more of this i'm
so so glad i got that only just
this is this is like this is like if if
nurse ratched was your bitter drunk aunt
it's just the worst combination of i
mean do you i guess she doesn't realize
what you
you're viscerally
repulsive and unappealing in every way
to everyone like
and i guess she doesn't realize that
about i mean because one of the
prerequisites to be somebody like that
is you have to have no self-awareness
whatsoever
that first of all telltale sign of
self-awareness
or lack thereof is when you're talking
to uh you know the phone and you have
the screen that close to your face
and you just know that that's what she
does to people in real life too can you
imagine that
she's up that close in your face talking
to you
you have to smell the stale uh white
wine on her breath
it you know you see that and you think
well that's uh okay that's a bitter
lonely cat lady
you know childless husbandless
and there's a chance of that but there's
also a very you know it's like a lot of
these people are married can you imagine
being married to that i would just i'd
have to move to siberia i don't think
there's any
there's no way to endure it
but what you have to realize is that
corporate hr departments it's actually
it's it's it's good that she decided to
post this
corporate hr departments are full of
people like this
maybe not quite that
extreme or that you know kind of openly
blatantly
repulsive but full of people like this
in the sense of being totally drunk on
the little bit of power that they have
okay they have a little bit then this
you find this in bureaucracies all over
bureaucracies
and um
big corporations are all bureaucracies
too and in effect people that work at
these hr departments these major
companies are in effect bureaucrats
really glorified um and and this is what
you find just a bunch of people who are
given this little sliver of power it's
like not that much but it's a little bit
and they have they have little ways and
sometimes not so little ways that they
can
make your life difficult and they just
love doing it
they whatever they can do whatever a
small amount of power you give to them
they become like she's an actual super
villain she's this is what it's the kind
of video you would see a super villain
in a comic book movie record like the
only thing i was missing was and i was
expecting it honestly was the
maniacal laughter which usually that's
the kind of thing you see in movies all
the time where the villain comes up this
evil plan and then laughs about it and
it's like you never see people do that
in real life even the most evil people
but um
i was i was expecting it there the kind
of joker cackle at the end
she's become a super villain because of
a little power that she got from the hr
department
but here's the great thing here's the
the happy ending to that is that she she
begins the video by saying be very
careful what you put on social media
well she probably should have taken her
own advice because apparently now her
employer has been made aware of this
video and is looking into it and uh
they're gonna have to make some
decisions about whether they wanna
whether they wanna keep her around so
that's at least a happy ending to that
have you ever looked at your credit card
statement and been shocked by the
interest rate did you know that you
could actually roll all of your credit
card debt into one monthly payment at a
lower fixed interest rate lower your
interest rate and save with a credit
card consolidation loan from late stream
rates start at 5.7
apr with auto pay and excellent credit
plus the rate is fixed so we'll never go
up over the life of the loan so you get
some stability there as well we could
all use more of that i think financially
especially right now you can get a loan
from 5 000 100 000 and there are
absolutely no fees you can even get your
money as soon as the day you apply light
stream believes that people with good
credit deserve a better loan experience
and that's exactly what they deliver
putting their money where their mouth is
so just for my listeners apply now to
get a special interest rate discount and
you can save even more the only way to
get this discount uh is to go to
lightstream.com walsh i'll spell that
for you that's l-i-g-h-t-s-t-r-e-a-m.com
walsh
subject to credit approval rates range
from 5.73 apr to 19.99 apr and include
0.5 auto pay discount lowest rate
requires excellent credit terms and
condition apply and offers are subject
to change without notice visit
lightstream.com walsh for more
information
let's get now to the comment
know their section
they're the sweet baby gang
let's see
dawn says matt i hate to break it to you
but i think the sweet baby gang your
detractors and probably even your wife
all assume that you're going to die a
slightly goofy death if not bees than
something else my money's on tripping
while running up the stairs in the dark
to get away from the scary spiders that
your wife shut you in with or maybe some
elaborate scenario where you're trying
to avoid changing a diaper but through a
series of events you end up causing your
own death that would be the most fitting
end for me something like that and i
think i can't disagree with you i can't
even ban you from the show for that
because i think you're probably right
um and at least if that happens then
i'll be i'll be true i guess in a way i
was worried about not dying a noble
death
and how that might affect sweet baby
gang the situation would put you guys in
but um i think you're right in a way
that would be it would be the truest i'd
be the truest to my role as the leader
of the sweet baby gang if i were to die
in such a way another comment says the
the massacre you described in
nigeria was almost certainly organized
religious terrorism
it was not the lone nutcase model the
usa specializes in good try matt
i don't know what you're what you think
i was trying i was just reporting what
happened
and
i think you're certainly right it was
probably
terrorism
and this is the point that i made last
week when we heard from the left that oh
the mass shootings that only happened in
the united states
no in fact
mass shootings and mass violence of
various different kinds they happen all
across the world and all throughout
history
they just they might manifest themselves
in different ways so if a if you have a
violent nihilistic sort of person
in nigeria then it's very likely they're
going to join an organized terrorist
organization if they live in mexico
they're probably going to join a cartel
um if they live in the united states
depending on where they live in the
united states they might just kind of
fester in their mom's basement before
they explode one day or if they live in
the city they might join a street gang
like all this stuff manifests itself in
this in in different ways but it's the
same sort of thing
that's my point
um
let's see hoosier says lol to all those
email replies from the critics sweet
bigot gang
that's i think we got to get that on a
shirt i know that might be one step too
far for the daily wire but i'll see
sweet picket gang
um
let's see
the other one says that what is a
woman's sequels are going to be better
than the star wars sequels hands down
well that's
yes but that's then again
you know as long as they get above a d
minus then they'll be better than that
so that's probably not saying much
um
marsha says how do you respond to the
feminists who say that you ignored them
or didn't include them in your film the
british gender critical feminists seem
really upset about that yeah i can't
remember if we talked about that on the
show yet but this is a this is a thing
online there's um a whole sort of group
of feminists especially in uh in the uk
who've been
uh who
refer to themselves as gender critical
but they are derisively called uh you
know the turfs trans-exclusionary
radical feminists that's what the trans
activists call them but anyway
um there's there's
apparently been quite a lot of
discussion in that community especially
in the uk about this film and about
whether or not
uh they should champion it given that
i'm a you know that i'm i'm a scary
right winger and i'm a man you know
um and then there's also been this
accusation that we didn't include that
we excluded them from the film
of course the truth of the matter there
is that um as i've said before we
we made this film we cast a very wide
net we wanted to talk to all the people
we possibly could
and um but not everybody wanted to talk
to us
and we did reach out to
some feminists and we found that they
the ones we reached out to anyway didn't
want to talk to us
but
as i as i keep repeating uh my mantra on
this thing when it comes to gender
ideology is that
i'm willing to join forces with anybody
to bring this down like for for this
specific battle
you stand against gender ideology and
the madness of gender ideology and you
stand for biological reality on this
subject then yes we could be allies in
this particular fight
that's my position
uh daniel says matt i agree with the
criticism made by jason whitlock and the
commenter you responded to yesterday
erasing god from the film is a fatal
flaw it's good but it's good but hard to
recommend as you did not ground your
message in scripture
well yeah i read jason's colony he wrote
about the film and i texted back and
forth with him a little bit about it
i'll be on i'll be on a show i think in
a couple days so we'll talk probably
more about this
i just don't agree with the critique at
all
let me respond first of all to what you
what you just said
uh jason didn't say that i erased god
but that's what you're saying and that's
that's absurd okay
you cannot erase god
if you're speaking truth okay any
pursuit or defense of truth is not going
to erase god as you say quite the
opposite
the question is whether the film should
have had an explicitly sort of
theological message should we have gone
through the entire journey and then i go
back to uh to
my to home and i talked to my wife
spoiler alert and when i'm talking to
her should she have
answered the question
by pulling out the bible and quoting
genesis or something like that
that's the question and i emphatically
believe
that we handled that the right way by
not making this an explicitly
theological film
that would have minimized the cultural
impact in a major way by giving the left
an escape hatch and making it seem as
though
um
you know criticism of gender ideology is
faith-based and religious in nature
that's what they want to believe that's
what they want to claim
it's not true
because in fact gender ideology
is faith-based and religious
uh as i said yesterday if somebody if
somebody says to you two plus two equals
five
your response i'm pretty sure is going
to be
no it equals four you're not going to
say no god says it equals four he does
say that but you don't need to say that
when you're responding to the question
you just need to reassert the reality
um if you did say oh god says it's for
it would sound as though your
mathematical claims are somehow
doctrinal or religious when they are not
so that was the approach
really the idea is to to reach as wide
an audience as we can with this
um and to keep the message as basic and
simple as we possibly can
that's what we're trying to achieve with
the film
other people can make other films that
deal with it in other ways that's one of
the things like anytime you make
a piece of content
you always get this it's a very weird
criticism you get from people
where they where they'll they'll
criticize you for making that content
and not something else why did you make
that instead of this
okay it's it's a little bit like i don't
know walking into a pizza shop and then
saying why are you guys making pizza i'm
not serving ice cream instead
because we're making pizzas this is what
we're doing like if you want ice cream
go to ice cream shop or make your start
your own this is a
you can't do everything
so um this was our approach to this film
this is the film we wanted to make and
uh
but there are many other ways to
approach this issue and i'm
would eagerly suggest that anyone who
wants to make any kind of film or
anything dealing with this issue in
other ways should certainly do that well
in the fray and the utter mess uh and
the mass hysteria over the release of my
documentary what is a woman you you may
have missed the what is a woman
collection over at dailywire.com
shop the collection is complete with a
pre-order from my upcoming book what is
a woman also t-shirt stickers and yet
another limited edition patch in my
highly coveted
sought-after patch program the
definition of a woman patch highlights
the circular logic of the left going
around and around until the failed
explanation loses all meaning and much
like the age-old symbol of the serpent
eating its own tail disappears from
reality completely that's a lot to
accomplish with one patch so go to
dailywire.comshop and check it out now
let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
well after amber heard really crap the
bed so to speak in trial and was found
liable for defamation against johnny
depp
there's been a popular outcry to put
depp back into any forthcoming pirates
of the caribbean films now i think a
better plan would be to put nobody in
the forthcoming pirates of the caribbean
films and just stop making them entirely
they got one mildly amusing film out of
a theme park ride the sequels provide
proved i think that there wasn't much
juice left to squeeze out of it not
everything needs to be a
five-decade-long franchise that's just
my opinion the fans disagree which has
led to a campaign to get depp back
involved in the franchise and that has
precipitated an effort in the reverse
from the last stragglers still left
trying to salvage the credibility of the
metoo movement to ensure that depp never
stars in any film ever again in fact
one stanford professor has taken it a
step further she's decided that the best
way to keep johnny depp out of the
pirates of the caribbean
is to cancel pirates of the caribbean
and the best way to do that is to cancel
pirates so she tweeted
captain jack and pirates of the
caribbean whitewashed and erased slaves
and slavery from the 18th century
caribbean where its practice was
probably the most cruel in the world
pirates were often from uh far from the
freedom fighters the film portrayed but
were slave holders themselves
in case you need another reason to hate
johnny derp the pirates franchise is
deeply racially problematic in some even
the fictional character derps fans love
and think as a real depiction of derp
himself is almost certainly a racist
sociopath
now the first problem here
is that a stanford professor is using
the grade school insult johnny derp
and this is especially embarrassing and
ineffective
when the other side has a much
much better in grade school insult in
amber turd
that's actually one of the greatest name
rhyming insults of all time it might be
the best that anyone's ever come up with
i mean given you know the backstory
behind it
and it goes to show why you should never
leave a turd in your bed if your name
rhymes with turd
or even if it doesn't actually it's a
good
good way to live but more to the point
professor michelle dober is trying to
enlighten us by revealing that pirates
were actually unsavory characters in
real life well this is stunning i mean
next she'll tell me that there was never
really a pirate in real life with a hook
for a hand who was stalked by a
crocodile with a clock in its belly as
he tried to hunt down and murder a
flying boy in a green suit with a fairy
sidekick i mean i'd always thought that
pirates of the caribbean was a
documentary and peter pan was at least
based on a true story
thank god we have college professors
around to correct the record
i don't even want to ask okay whether
there was ever really a prince
who turned into a scary buffalo type
creature and lived in a castle with his
talking candlestick and a collection of
sentient kitchen utensils i just i
couldn't bear to know the truth
ignorance is bliss just leave the rest
of the fairy tales alone please
now aside from these stunning
revelations i think that there are
a couple of other things happening here
one is that we see how these people
simply do not want anyone to experience
any joy at all they are determined to
find a reason why anything that you
enjoy however mild and superficial the
the diversion may be
they wanna they wanna tell you why it is
as they say deeply problematic
and the real problem for them is that
you have not requested their permission
ahead of time before recklessly deciding
to enjoy something this is an oversight
that they cannot allow to pass unchecked
notice how the professor makes sure to
mention the fans of the film
and of dep's character she's very
unsubtly drawing guilty you know sort of
guilt by association here the character
of jack sparrow is a racist sociopath
she says
and you like the character so what does
that say about you
never mind the fact by the way that
disney already thought of the pc
problems that may arise from the
relationship between piracy and slavery
and they actually included a scene in
one of the films where they mentioned
that jack sparrow once uh freed 100
slaves from from a ship like that's
that's a story line in one of the films
so the professor is trying to out woke
disney but disney is one step ahead as
always
another point is that
you know she thinks it's a revelation to
us
that pirates were often cruel and
violent people she thinks we'll be
shocked to learn that pirates were
racist
and she only assumes it would be
surprised because most likely
she just learned this herself
i'm guessing she was mad about you know
the amber heard verdict and so she
googled the true history of jack sparrow
and then she found out that jack
sparrow's true history goes back to a
theme park ride so then she just googled
bad stuff about pirates generally and
was scandalized by what she discovered
she's only scandalized though and
believes we will be also
because as a leftist she has no
understanding of world history
this is why leftists are constantly
coming up with new historical figures to
cancel even fictional ones on the basis
that uh they were racist or violent or
whatever else
what they don't understand is that is
that for most of history
almost everybody was racist by our
standards today and the entire history
of humanity is soaked in blood and
plagued by violence and defined by war
and conquest from the dawn of
civilization until now
as normal people we know this it's not
news to us
we understand historical figures within
that context and we judge them
accordingly
and we also know that the the uh the
pirate of fiction
bears very very little resemblance to
the pirate of history we know that
doesn't bother us we're okay with that
we can compartmentalize these things
nobody is watching pirates of the
caribbean and feeling influenced to uh
you know go somewhere and become a
pirate today
especially because that would require
you to move to somalia probably so
that's already enough of a disincentive
we have no trouble with any of this
she does because she is a utopian
leftist with no understanding of history
no insight into human nature and nothing
to offer the world but new and
innovative ways to be offended by
utterly inconsequential things
and that is why today
professor michelle dober is cancelled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavo valdoski
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike cormina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matt wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22. a
senior obama white house staffer calls
us us whom everyone loves so a threat to
democracy the carolina panthers add a
dude to the cheerleading squad
rose and bees become fish in california
check it out on the michael knowles show